europa
ganymede
enceladus
all moons in our solar system with one
thing in common
they're suspected to contain liquid
water below their icy
surfaces and even further out we have
some tantalizing evidence that maybe
worlds around neptune and
potentially even uranus as well could
host liquid water even pluto might have
a layer of liquid water hiding somewhere
underneath that icy crust
experts think that if there is life
beyond earth
these massive oceans are the place where
most likely to find it in our solar
system
nasa scientists and oceanographers are
working towards missions that hopefully
will end up looking for and hopefully
finding some forms of life which may be
very different from ours on those other
planetary bodies
there's an increasing number of missions
and proposals to explore these untapped
water bodies
starting with an expedition to one of
jupiter's moons
it's called the europa clipper mission
europa clipper mission is nasa's next
foray into the jupiter system and we're
going to search for all of these amazing
indicators of habitability and
potentially life at europa exploring our
solar systems subsurface water oceans is
one of the next big steps in space
exploration
in 1977 during a mission to photograph
the barren volcanic floor along the
mid-ocean ridge
scientists found something that totally
changed our understanding of where life
can exist
they collected 3 000 photos of the sea
floor developed the film on board the
ship
and as they were going through the
footage which was very boring because it
was just barren volcanic rock they came
across 13 photos that had pictures of
large clams in them
shortly after that the deep submersible
alvin that takes people to the bottom of
the ocean arrived on the scene
and dived on those sites
and found the oases of life amidst all
sorts of shimmering water that was
clearly emanating out of the sea floor
the sea water percolating into the sea
floor was being heated by magma and then
rising to discharge as hydrothermal
vents
and those vents were supporting a
previously unknown ecosystem
before then it was thought that most
animal life depended on energy from the
sun
if you move more than about 50 to 100
meters away from a vent the sea floor is
barren
and the question is how do these vents
support the life
well clearly photosynthesis on which
most of our life relies on our planet
won't work at the bottom of the ocean
because it's dark and so there's no
sunlight
so that photosynthesis will not be
operative
however we do have these gases that
contain a lot of energy
and because of that there are bacteria
living around these areas and other
microorganisms
that are able to extract energy
from
those gases
and use it to produce organic matter
and that matter feeds an array of exotic
animals
when i first saw them my mind was blown
at
several things one how beautiful they
are but also how big some of the animals
are some of the creatures that you see
down there
are tube worms that can grow six to ten
feet long
foot long clams
big muscles and in fact the diversity
around these vents has been likened to
that of the diversity of a tropical
rainforest
this discovery has big implications for
planetary bodies in the universe with
water regardless of whether or not
they're close enough to harness the
energy of their host star
it suggests that there's a possibility
that there might be life on other
planetary bodies that have water
and so in some ways this discovery is
helping
change our ideas about the potential for
life on other planets
[Music]
in the decades since the hydrothermal
vent discovery
evidence has piled up for oceans in the
outer solar system
both the galileo probe that visited
jupiter
and the cassini probe that visited
saturn
were equipped with an onboard device
called a magnetometer which was able to
give substantial evidence for liquid
oceans
think of it as like a fancy compass
basically any liquid water ocean if it
has salts in it it can conduct
electricity and that means that if you
have a world nearby like jupiter or
saturn that has its own magnetic field
they can
influence each other and we can pick
that up with a magnetometer
so this is how galileo was able to
provide tantalizing evidence of liquid
water oceans around europa and a couple
of other moons in the jovian system
but life
as far as we know
needs more than water
there needs to be an energy source like
the sun or similar processes that create
hydrothermal vents
so when the voyager mission flew past
jupiter's moon io in 1979 and witnessed
volcanic plumes
scientists were thrilled to confirm that
these frozen bodies were more active
than previously thought
so we thought that the further out we
got from the sun the less interesting
the solar system would be
boy were we wrong europa is far away
from the sun it's five times farther
than earth and that means that it's much
colder europa should be frozen solid but
it's not why is that well we think that
there are two reasons the first is heat
that's generated by radioactive elements
in europa's core this is similar to how
earth's interior stays molten and really
hot
as certain elements decay they give off
some heat but we don't think that could
be enough
the other thing that we think is keeping
europa warm is something called tidal
heating now this happens because as
europa orbits around jupiter its orbit
is not a perfect circle instead it's a
bit of an ellipse and that means when
europa is orbiting jupiter sometimes
it's a little bit closer sometimes it's
a bit further away and so the moon
actually goes like this
and that tidal flexing generates heat
just as if you were to
you know rub your hands together you
generate some heat due to that friction
so we think that that also is helping to
keep europa's ocean liquid potentially
for a very very long time
tidal heating is also the reason for the
volcanic activity on io observed by
voyager
but there are other reasons for making
europa the top priority
while some moons in our solar system
have many craters europa has few
and this means that the surface is
probably very young due to an ocean that
causes the surface to warm and crack
changing the landscape and erasing
craters
based off of what we know of europa now
we know it has a liquid water ocean we
know it has some building blocks that
could potentially be used
for organic molecules to make life and
we know it has an energy source
so all of these lines of evidence point
towards having the ingredients for life
not only that but this intense tidal
heating could lead to hydrothermal
events down at the sea floor of europa
and so this is why it's at the top of
our list to study as a world that could
host life of its own
[Music]
now all we need to do is get there
europa clipper is prepared to launch in
2024 we have
really amazing cameras that are going to
take higher resolution images than ever
before we've got some imaging
spectrometers these are instruments that
will be able to tell us what the
composition of the surface is
we'll have a magnetometer a fancy
compass to be able to understand more
about europa's interior ocean we'll even
have a radar sounder so that we can look
for near surface water reservoirs too
in addition to that we're going to have
a few other particles and fields
instruments to try to understand the the
plasma environment all of those ions
that are zipping around in the jupiter
system we'll be able to understand those
because they're important too
color and infrared cameras will map the
surface and search for hot spots where
material from within europa possibly the
ocean may reach the surface
it will be the first mission sent to
specifically study a moon other than our
own
the mission will place the clipper
spacecraft which is longer than a
basketball court in orbit around jupiter
where it will perform about 40 flybys of
europa
now ideally we would love to send
clipper and go straight into orbit
around europa but the conditions in the
jovian system don't make that the best
option for us there's a bit of radiation
that's right in and around where europa
sits in orbit around jupiter and while
that's not necessarily bad for life in
fact it could make some molecules and
some ions that might be good for life
it's not so good for our spacecraft so
instead we are planning on doing flybys
of europa where we go in we get our data
we get out and cool off for a bit send
that data back to earth and it gives us
as scientists plenty of time to look
over things before the next pass
the spacecraft may even be able to
sample particles high above europa's
surface
during past earth observations and
observations from the hubble space
telescope
scientists have seen something that
looks like plumes of water or other
material on europa
clipper will be equipped with the right
tools and will be able to fly close
enough to analyze those plumes if they
do indeed exist
this would be similar to saturn's moon
enceladus where free sample from his
ocean is is actively venting into space
now this would be really exciting for us
because some of the instruments aboard
europa clipper could collect some of
those ice grains if they're there or
some of the gases and be able to tell us
what they're made of and help us get a
glimpse of the composition of that ocean
although the main goal of clipper is to
understand habitability in europa
not all of the questions regarding life
can be answered from flybys
that's why nasa is proposing a follow-up
mission to launch in the next couple of
decades that could land on europa
the europa lander mission concept is
something that we've been developing
that could potentially visit a world
like europa or another ocean world one
day
this concept
could have some type of legs to be able
to stabilize itself on a really
treacherous terrain
and a lot of engineers are developing
sampling tools that could cut into very
very cold ice
the european space agency is also
sending a probe in the next couple of
years called the jupiter icy moons
explorer or juice
it will spend at least three years
studying jupiter and the habitability of
three of jupiter's moons
europa
callisto and ganymede
the last of which was recently found to
have possible water vapor coming from
its surface
and there are even more ambitious
proposals to explore subsurface oceans
in the far future
there are even robotic snakes there's
one that's called eels the exobiology
extant life surveyor we love our
acronyms at nasa this is something that
could could slither down into cracks or
crevices
where biosignatures might be hiding
potentially protected from radiation so
there are all sorts of exciting concepts
on the horizon they're even like these
hoppers that could even take some of
that water ice and then melt it and use
the steam to sort of puff to bounce
around to go to different places
finding even microorganisms would
undoubtedly change our understanding of
life and the boundaries of the habitable
zone
the area around a star which we think
could support life as we know it
really it's caused us to change
our
ideas for where we might look for life
and how abundant habitable conditions
might be in the universe
since many planets around other stars
known as exoplanets are now thought to
contain liquid water
these expeditions may tell us more about
which of these planets are potentially
habitable and bring us closer to
answering the age-old question of are we
alone
ever since we as human beings first
started to look up and
wonder about stars about other planets
other worlds
we wondered if we were alone
you know this universe is so vast so
immense so amazing
are there other worlds that could be
more incredibly diverse beyond our
wildest dreams and have life of their
own or are we just incredibly horribly
alone i hope it's the first one
you